PAUL IRISH: All right.
Good morning, good evening,
good afternoon.
BORIS SMUS: What's up?
PAUL IRISH: We're bringing to
you the first installment of
what we're going to be calling
HTML5 Rocks Live, a video
series talking about--
ERIC BIDELMAN: What are we
going to talk about?
PAUL IRISH: I don't know.
BORIS SMUS: Everything.
PAUL IRISH: Building web apps.
BORIS SMUS: Building web apps.
PAUL IRISH: What's new in the
browser, and how to do amazing
things inside the browser,
I guess.
BORIS SMUS: How to do that.
PAUL IRISH: Today, we
have a few things
we're going to show.
We're going to talk about the
new Vertical Timeline in
Chrome Developer tools, we're
going to talk about Device
Detection, and then we're also
going to talk about the File
System API, and some
new stuff for that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Before
we do that, we
should introduce ourselves.
PAUL IRISH: Sounds good.
BORIS SMUS: Good point.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So who
are you, fine sir?
PAUL IRISH: My name
is Paul Irish.
We're all on the Chrome
Developer Relations team.
I like to focus on the Chrome
Developer Tools and
Cross-browser, and all
sorts of good stuff.
BORIS SMUS: My name is.
Boris.
I mostly the focus on mobile
stuff and used to be on
Extensions.
ERIC BIDELMAN: What's
up, everybody?
My name's Eric Bidelman, also
[? on Chrome Developer ?]
Relations, focusing mainly
on HTML5 awesomeness for
building web apps.
PAUL IRISH: Right.
So first, I think we'll
just go right into it.
I want to show off some new
features inside the Chrome Dev
Tools, and so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to
share my screen.
It should be good.
Cool.
So I wanted to show some new
stuff, and so what I'm going
to do is actually going to use a
demo that was written by the
government called Hakim,
who goes by hakimel
on Twitter and GetHub.
Really good stuff, and so this
is a little tricky because
you're going to be watching it
and the frame rate won't be so
hot, and it's all about smooth
graphics, but you're just
going to have to bear
with me here.
So what this is, is a little
demo where we can scroll
through a list of items and
there is a visual effect as
the items kind of scroll
into view.
Pretty cool.
And so Hakim released this
sometime last week, and
everyone was really into it.
As so I was looking at the code
behind it and I was like,
hm, this is cool.
And I was wondering if we could
actually make it any
smoother at all.
I learned a few things about how
Chrome deals with hardware
accelerated graphics
and was like--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Did you see like
visual jank, and were you
actively investigating?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's a
great demo, but--
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
I mean, I did.
So we call it jank oftentimes
inside the team.
Jank is just like stuttering
and the absence of buttery
smoothness.
BORIS SMUS: Devoid of.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, exactly.
So it was good, but I was like,
I think we can get it a
little bit better.
So I'm going to show you a new
tool inside the Chrome Dev
Tools that we're going to use
to kind of explore this.
So you'll see it here.
Right inside the Timelines
Panel on the Timelines,
there's these two buttons right
underneath Resources.
And it doesn't look like it's
very much now, but we'll see
it in a little bit.
Now right now to enable this,
you're going to have to do a
little bit funky stuff.
You're going to go to About
Flags, where you can turn on
all sorts of good stuff, and
you're going to search for
Developer Tool Experiments.
You enable that.
And then back inside your Dev
Tools, you click on Settings
and down at the bottom is all
this cool experiments.
Now of course, all this stuff is
kind of super experimental.
If it breaks, too bad.
But this is the new Vertical
Overview Mode in
the Timeline Panel.
And you'll be seeing it
soon anyways, but
here's what it does.
First, I'm going to keep it
off, and I'm just going to
record, and I'll go down and
scroll a little bit.
OK, cool.
Stop recording, and now I can
click and I can drag, and I
can see some things.
Mostly, it just paints all along
the side, and we can see
how big the paints are,
here's a scroll event.
It looks like this scroll event
is actually taking up
quite a bit of time.
How long is this?
211 milliseconds for the
entire duration.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So Paul, is that
the call-back for the
scroll, or what is that?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
The self time of the actual
event itself is very, very
small, but what it does
is considerable.
So that one scroll event
kicks off a lot of
Recalculate Style Layout.
So Recalculate Style Layout is
basically, we're matching all
the CSS against the DOM, and
then recalculating all the
geometry of the page.
And when you see Recalc Style
followed by Layout, and that
pair going back and forth,
there's usually an ability to
optimize that.
So we're going to look into
what we can do there.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So that's
sort of an instant red
flag on your web app?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, exactly.
BORIS SMUS: So could you talk a
little bit about the yellow
bar has the bright yellow and
then the less bright yellow?
PAUL IRISH: Oh yeah.
The beginning is the
self time, right?
So if I'm highlighting over
here and we have the self
time, it's basically that
sometimes you'll see this.
You'll see this with
event handlers.
You'll also see this
with Ajax.
What the actual event was is the
very beginning, and then
it's effect is captured by the
whole thing, so the scroll
handler and all its effects.
PAUL IRISH: So what I'm actually
going to do is I'm
going to clear this out,
we'll switch over to
Vertical, and record.
Now, it's a little
bit different.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh that's nice.
PAUL IRISH: So I'm going to do
that once more, because I'm--
here we go.
So this is a much different
view, right?
These are all frames.
So one thing you'll notice is
along the top is a time from
zero to four seconds, but if
we zoom in to the frames,
you'll see that the time
scale is actually the
length of each frame.
And what's the optimized, best
frame rate that we could have?
ERIC BIDELMAN: 60.
BORIS SMUS: 60.
PAUL IRISH: 60 frames
per second.
And how many milliseconds
per frame is that?
BORIS SMUS: 16.66 repeated.
PAUL IRISH: Correct.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Were you
a math major, Paul?
This is good, man.
PAUL IRISH: Blue ribbon.
So in an ideal world, you have
16.6 milliseconds per frame,
nothing more.
And your entire everything
just happens inside 16
milliseconds.
Now, it happens that you
take more than this.
And so we've just dived in,
and we can see that these
frames are actually taking
40, 60, 100, 80--
they're are a lot more
than just that 16.
But we're able to see
exactly what is
happening inside that time.
So we have a scroll event and
it's doing a bunch of stuff,
and so I can click in and see
what's going on inside that
scroll event.
So there's a lot of things
happening, but it looks like--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Sorry, were
you projecting that?
Are we projecting the
screen right now?
PAUL IRISH: No, but we'll
switch over to that.
So this is Scripts Panel, but
I'm just going to bring this
up inside my Code Editor
so everyone can see it.
We have a Scroll Handler that
is bound to Update, and in
Update, we do all this magic.
And that's good, but one thing
that I learned a few months
ago is it's actually quite
bad to bind to
either Scroll or Resize.
Those events fire quite a bit,
and typically, you'll be
binding those so that you can
update the UI of the page.
But we have a first class API
designed for redrawing the UI
of the page when the browser's
ready, which is called--
ERIC BIDELMAN: RAF,
RequestAnimationFrame,
everybody's best friend.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
RequestAnimationFrame or RAF,
as we abbreviate it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So let me
ask you a question.
The Scroll and Resize, those
always fire quite more often
than 16 FPS, right?
No, or?
PAUL IRISH: They fire a lot.
ERIC BIDELMAN: They fire away
more than you should be
updating UI, right?
PAUL IRISH: Browser engineers
really just don't like it when
you bind them.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Users just don't
either, because that
means there's jank, word of the
day, inside of your app.
PAUL IRISH: So what we're going
to do is we're going to
change the implementation.
Instead of binding to
Scroll, we're just
going to bind to RAF.
So the browser's going to
optimize that to 60
frames if it can.
So I'm going to take this scroll
event, and I'm going to
copy in a little
RequestAnimationFrame shim,
and then I'm going to replace
the scroll with some RAF loop.
So this is just a recursive
loop to call
RequestAnimationFrame.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So for those
not familiar with
RequestAnimationFrame,
I'm not seeing a--
so set time out, right?
People use set time out, there's
a time that you recall
your callback.
That's not the case with
RequestAnimationFrame?
Can you explain that
a little bit?
PAUL IRISH: Well, it
is a callback.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, but you're
not [? parsing ?] an
explicit time that you're
calling the callback?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
You're just saying,
hey, browser, you
take care of this.
This is the function that I
want to be called, and you
call it as much as you can.
And one of the things that's
happening is the browser's
starting to get smart.
So if your callback starts to
take so much time, it's
actually going to optimize
your animation
for 30 frames a second.
So you're always blowing past
the 16.6 milliseconds, but
it's going to say, hey,
we're just going to be
30 frames per second.
Now, the big thing about these
30 and 60 numbers is that your
monitor refreshes at 60 hertz.
So Chrome is actually able to
make sure that your canvas, or
your CSS, changes are being
painted to the screen and
synchronized to the refresh
rate of the monitor, which
means it's as smooth as it can
be, which is really powerful.
So this is the best way to
get the best graphics.
ERIC BIDELMAN: The other benefit
too is that if your
app isn't visible to the user,
RequestAnimationFrame will
stop calling that callback
altogether.
So if the users can't see
something visually being
updated on the page, then
there's no reason to waste
that CPU [INAUDIBLE]
extra calculation.
That's another benefit.
PAUL IRISH: So this is one of
the cool things on Chrome for
Android is that Chrome for
Android is the first mobile
browser that has
RequestAnimationFrame, so you
have some [? cool ?]
canvas loop using
RequestAnimationFrame and you
switch to another tab, that is
not still running.
[INAUDIBLE].
BORIS SMUS: So here, you're
not bound to any event
handler, so this will rerender
all the time, regardless of if
you're [INAUDIBLE]
or not, right?
PAUL IRISH: Correct.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Do
we like that?
PAUL IRISH: No.
Good question.
This is a very naive
implementation.
In an ideal world, we would have
scroll kicks off this RAF
loop, and then at some point,
we like to bounce the scroll
event, kick off RAF, and then
cancel out RAF when the
scrolling is done.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, so we want
a time out or something.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So there's a way to kind of like
have Scroll and Resize
kick off RAF but
work together.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So the
call [INAUDIBLE]
is similar to Set Timeout, you
can cancel, you can request,
it's just that time difference
that you're not [? parsing ?]
in.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So we'll go back to
the timeline.
And now that I have RAF in,
before, you kind of see all
these uneven bars, but there's
not a lot of context.
Now with RAF in, I've saved,
I'm going to refresh.
And once it's in, I'm going to
record our new thing, and
you'll see quite a bit of
difference down in the timeline.
So--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Nice.
PAUL IRISH: It's already
moving, and
there's a lot of bars.
So I'm not touching anything and
the bars are just going.
And so you can see down here,
there's a lot of animation
frames firing.
So this is pretty cool, but what
we're able to see is that
the browser is giving us an
indication of how long all
these animation frames
are taking.
And so we're able to see when
there's big spikes, that means
that it's taking much longer
than it should and we're not
able to hit our 60 frames
per second.
So in an ideal world, 60 frames
per second means that
all these bars are just
completely flat.
But here, we have spikes.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is cool.
So this is like a visual
representation of
your code right now.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
And so these spikes
are jank, right?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah Let's
get rid of that.
PAUL IRISH: So we're going
to kill that jank.
So I'm just going to zoom in,
and you've really got to zoom
in pretty close.
So that looks pretty good.
And I'm going to switch--
OK, this looks pretty good.
We have this animation
frame, it fires, it
takes quite a while.
And we're going to look
into what's going on.
We got Recalculate Style
going on inside
of that, a few layouts.
We click into the Recalculate
Style, and it points to this
line in particular, which is
Offset Top, Offset Height.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Uh-oh.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
There's a few DOM properties
that cause a reflow, and
that's essentially what's
happening, is that the browser
has to say, hey, I don't know
what the Offset Top and Offset
Height is, but I need to
recalculate the entire
geometry of the page in order
to give you, the JavaScript,
an accurate number for
these two things.
And it has to do this--
actually the loop that it's in
is for every single item in
this list on every
single frame.
BORIS SMUS: Wow.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It seems
really wasteful.
PAUL IRISH: Totally wasteful.
It turns out that Offset Top and
Offset Height do not even
change for any of these
for the entire thing.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is why
it's hard to be a web
developer right here,
this sort of thing.
PAUL IRISH: That's true.
So let's see.
I'll go to the next iteration.
This is where this ended up.
So I spent some time with this,
and we ended up here
where we actually cache
some of these numbers.
So the Scroll Top we cache,
and make sure that if the
Scroll Top is not changed since
last time we went into
this RAF loop, we just
quit immediately.
And then we actually
do two loops.
One loop we do to go and get the
Offset Tops, and then we
do a second loop to go
make the changes.
Now, the reason that we actually
do two loops is back
on HTML5 Rocks a while ago, we
talked about reflows and
optimizing for those, and we
talked about that pattern of
Recalculate Style Layout,
Recalculate Style Layout.
And here, we were asking for
what is the Offset Top, and
immediately using Class List
to change the class of some
DOM elements.
And then we would just do that,
and then we'd do about
100 per loop.
And so that is totally
wasteful.
So here, we're able to get all
of our information out of the
DOM in one move, one pass, and
then make all of our changes
in another pass, and that's
really the most optimized way
to handle this.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's interesting
that something
like two loops, you wouldn't--
[INAUDIBLE] two loops would be
more efficient, oftentimes,
than touching the DOM like you
would in single loop, but
maybe that's something you
have to do, you have to
consider that, right?
DOM is the bottleneck here.
PAUL IRISH: DOM is the
bottleneck, not two loops.
I mean, I could make it do 10
loops, and that'd probably
still be more effective than
the back and forth
inside of the loop.
ERIC BIDELMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
calculate a Fibonacci sequence
in there someplace
or something?
BORIS SMUS: Basically what
you're doing is you're getting
the updates and then doing
the renders separately.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, exactly.
BORIS SMUS: But how does a web
developer know which of these
things cause a reflow?
ERIC BIDELMAN: I was just
thinking of that.
Like is there a best
practices?
BORIS SMUS: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: OK, so
that's fair.
So one, you could be like, DOM
Properties That Cause Reflow.
Just use your favorite search
engine and ask.
The best resource on this
is on this site.
This is actually a Chrome
engineer, Tony.
And he just looked into the Web
Kit source and found out
that these are all the
properties, these are all the
methods, and all these things
force the browser to go ask
and they all force a
reflow, if you ask
for all these things.
So if you know that,
because you do.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Step one.
PAUL IRISH: And then you're over
here, you see Recalculate
Style Layout, Recalculate
Style, and this actually
pointing to a line number,
a file and line number.
And I click 44, and
it highlights this
line 44 right here.
It's a pretty good indication.
And so if I move over, this is
the new and updated one.
And I'll do a timeline
recording of this.
Good.
Now, it's hard just to show on
the screen cast, but we're a
little bit smoother,
and inside--
yes, that's what I wanted.
So we only have a single
Recalc Style and then a
layout, as opposed to back and
forth and back and forth.
So that's exactly what we want
to be able to see, is that
we're only getting a single
one of each per frame.
That is optimal.
It's hard to get.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So remind us what
we were seeing before.
We were seeing orange mixed in
with purple, or were we seeing
higher bars?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah so yellow and
orange is script, and then
purple is rendering.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's the
browser doing its thing,
whatever [INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
And so it's hard to sometimes
say what the rendering is,
whereas the script is basically
always your code.
But when we see this purple back
and forth back and forth
Recalc Style Layout, that's
just a bad idea.
So you're able to kind of do
these hovers here and see that
we have a call stack, we're in
Update Anim Loop, and get an
idea of where this
is happening.
So the cool thing here is that
we're able to get some
information from the Dev Tools
on what exactly and where
exactly we can optimize
better.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's great that
I don't have to memorize
all those properties, the Dev
Tools can help me there.
Can you go back to the
timeline again?
I just want to show people
that-- we talked a little
about this before, but
RequestAnimationFrame is
continuing to fire, regardless
if you're scrolling these
lists or not.
So it probably is one
of these best
practices that you consider.
If the user's not engaging
with your page, then you
should probably cancel that and
not waste those callbacks.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
The quicker that you're able
to say, I don't need what's
going to happen inside this RAF
callback to happen, and
just cancel out of that
loop, the better.
And so that's [INAUDIBLE] we
ended up in this loop.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
But of course, if you
background it, it's
not going to fire.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
And if you're in another tab,
you're totally good.
So you should Google for this
demo and check it out, because
it's got a lot of other
community additions since the
last week or so.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's called Silly
List Scroll Effects?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
I think it's actually since
been named to stroll.js.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Of course
there's a .js for it.
PAUL IRISH: Of course.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That
was pretty rad.
Unfortunately, the screen, the
hangout doesn't do it justice.
PAUL IRISH: So go
check it out.
And if you want, go find
his GetHub [? repo ?]
and revert back to the very
original first commit, and
then you'll be able to see the
difference between the
original one with a considerable
amount of jank,
and the new ones, which
are smooth.
ERIC BIDELMAN: We
don't like jank.
That's cool, man.
Vertical Timeline, awesome.
Again, in the Dev Tools
Experiments, right?
So in by default yet, but--
PAUL IRISH: Yep.
BORIS SMUS: And this
is Canary, right?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
I'm trying this in Canary.
And you have to turn on two
separate experimental
flags to get it.
But it'll probably be coming
out into the main release
pretty soon.
Boris, do you want to show off
your cool device, device.js?
BORIS SMUS: Sure, sure.
ERIC BIDELMAN: What did
you make, Boris?
BORIS SMUS: I made a library.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah?
BORIS SMUS: It's called--
well, let me talk about maybe
briefly what sort of
spurred this on.
So basically, you've probably
heard of Responsive Design.
Yeah?
You guys heard of Responsive
Design?
ERIC BIDELMAN: I have. But
you could remind me.
BORIS SMUS: So it's actually
pretty broad, but the basic
idea of it is you use JSS Media
Queries to check the
width of your device, and style
the page appropriately.
So if you have a really
large screen, you
make it all fit well.
If you have a small screen, you
make it compress down and
do the right thing.
So there's a nice gallery
of pages that do this.
If you go to Mediaquery.--
could you do that, Eric?
Please type.
I'll just turn the screen
share back on.
Yes, so mediaquery.es is a nice
gallery of responsive--
oh, it's actually one of those
funky Delicious URLs.
Probably not this one.
Here.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Boris, you have
to show and tell your
own show and tell.
BORIS SMUS: So this page is
a gallery of a bunch of
Responsively Designed sites.
And you can see if I resize
that this site itself is
responsively designed.
But if I go to a particular
example, it also has this
feature where once it loads,
you'll see that as I resize
the browser, the page starts
flowing in different ways.
And what's happening basically
is there's a way to turn on
device width-specific CSS.
So that's great, right, if you
want to customize the way
things look.
But if you have like an m.
site or a specific tablet
site, this doesn't really
address anything.
And there's good reasons for
doing that, like you might
want to have better
performance, like
mobile-specific performance
optimizations, for example, or
you might want to load
custom JavaScript.
PAUL IRISH: You're going to
have different features,
depending on--
you're not going to have a drag
and drop file upload on
your phone site.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
So there's good reasons to use
responsive design, but there's
also good reasons
not to use it,
depending on your situation.
So there's a bunch of approaches
you can take.
The common one is server side
user agent detection.
So things like [? Wirfel ?]
you can just load it up here.
[? Wirfel. ?]
It's a really old school
project, but still being
maintained quite actively.
It goes back to the
days of WAP.
So if you guys remember, WAP was
the precursor to HTML on
mobile devices.
Anyway, these guys have a huge
database of devices and what
their capabilities
are, essentially.
There's similar other projects,
like Device Atlas,
and this is all kind of dark
secrets, like black magic-type
stuff, because there's just so
much complexity with User
Agent Parsing to do it right.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Can I ask you a
really important question?
BORIS SMUS: Sure.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So User
Agent Detection.
There's a lot of people that
say it's the devil,
people say it's good.
What's your opinion on it, and
should we be doing it in 2012?
BORIS SMUS: So that's
a good question.
I think the debate is still
pretty much open for now.
The main reason is it's still
so common is on the server
side, there's basically nothing
except for the user
agent that you can know about
the browser that's hitting
you, right?
So that's all you got
on the server.
And for performance reasons, you
want to do things on the
server in the initial loading
stage, right?
Like on a client, if you're
doing things like
feature-based detection to load
a specific layout, you're
inevitably doing a redirect,
right, or some sort of dynamic
script loading.
So that's going to have some
sort of performance hit.
PAUL IRISH: Some latency
cost, yes.
BORIS SMUS: Some latency cost.
So Device JS actually takes
that exact approach.
So it does client side detection
based on media
queries, which is, for browsers
that support media
queries, much nicer than just
relying on the server.
So you could say things like,
if I have this particular
width, load this version
of my web app.
So of course, the trade-off is
performance, but you end up
having much more future-proof
solution that's based on
feature detection, similar
to Modernizer.
So this is Device
JS on GetHub.
ERIC BIDELMAN: [INAUDIBLE]?
BORIS SMUS: It's right here.
And basically, the idea is
upfront, you can use Follow
Semantic approach.
Here, you could say use the Link
Rel Alternate tag, which
sort of specifies the list of
all the versions that your web
app should specify.
And this is great
for crawlers.
It's also just a generally
a best practice that
semantically says, this page
has multiple versions.
PAUL IRISH: That's really--
if you have multiple versions
of your site or app, this is
the best way to semantically
represent that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So I haven't
really seen this before.
Is this a new thing?
Are people doing this?
BORIS SMUS: It's really
old, actually.
PAUL IRISH: So yeah.
If you look in the spec,
for like HTML4 spec--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh, it's
back to four.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, we'll
go back to four.
It's in Five, too.
I don't want to be too retro.
But Link Rel Alternate means,
this document is available for
a different media type.
And the media type is defined in
that attribute, and it's a
media query.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Right.
PAUL IRISH: So that's
what we're doing.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's great that
we're using these old
paradigms and semantics that
have been out for a while but
are basically new.
BORIS SMUS: There's some
new stuff here too.
So in the old school
days, you would say
something like handheld.
There used to be this
media query
type and it was handheld.
That kind of is not really well
supported, didn't really
work so well.
So one thing you'll notice here
that you probably haven't
seen is this.
And what I'm doing here is
creating a media query that
should exist. It doesn't
currently exist, except for in
Mozilla with a Moz Touch-Enabled
flag.
And basically, the Device.js
library just makes
that happen for you.
PAUL IRISH: So as far as what
Device.js does, it reads these
Link tags, and does something?
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
So the idea is, you include
Device.js here, and it'll
parse the Link tags
in your page.
And given these media
attributes, do sort of the
right thing, the right thing
being it redirects to--
so first it checks which version
you should have. And
you would have these links in
all the versions of your page.
So it checks which version you
should have, and it compares
to your current version based
on the URL that you're
currently on.
And if you need to redirect,
then Device.js
will redirect you.
And that's it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So to clarify,
if I hit the Desktop landing
page on my mobile device or
something, it's going to
redirect me to the mobile
version that I'd specified
with Device.js?
BORIS SMUS: Yes.
So I can show you
a quick demo.
So here, I've got
a sample app.
It's linked to from the GetHub
page, but the default landing
page is just a redirector.
So if I go to Sample,
I get redirected
to the desktop page.
If I try going to the Phone
page, I'm getting redirected
to the Desktop page.
And the same thing will
happen on mobile.
So here's my little
setup here.
And you can see, it's
the same exact URL.
And if I go to the Root
page, I get redirected
to the phone version.
And this is all based on the
media queries that are
specified in the Link
alternates.
So I can also go to
the Desktop page.
Whoa, whoops.
This is interesting.
So anyway, that should
definitely work.
I'm not sure what
happened there.
So that's the idea.
And of course in some cases, you
might want to override the
version that you want
to load, right?
Like for development, or
generally, you probably want
to provide a way to specify
the version
that you want to use.
PAUL IRISH: So if you want to
override it and be like, you
know what, I thank you very much
for bringing me to the
phone view, but I want
the desktop view.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
So that's not to say that you
shouldn't provide the
functionality that your users
need on all of your versions,
but it's nice to have
an override.
So I've basically in this little
demo I provided, links.
And if you could show the
screen share of this.
So there's a phone version
and a tablet version.
And you can see if I go here,
what's basically happening is
there's a Device Equals thing
in the URL you can see.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Force equals.
BORIS SMUS: You can see Device
Equals Desktop here.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh, I see.
BORIS SMUS: And then when you
click that particular version,
then it'll redirect you with
Force Equals One, so that it
doesn't attempt to redirect
you again.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Could you kill
that with a Push [? state, ?]
replace that?
BORIS SMUS: Um, you could.
Definitely could.
PAUL IRISH: So using
just your API?
BORIS SMUS: [INAUDIBLE].
Could totally do this.
That's a good idea.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So can
you just quickly
explain again the touch?
So the Nonstandard
Touch-Enabled.
So basically, that's saying if
I'm on the screen and I don't
have touch capability, then
show me the desktop?
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Is there ever the
case where you're going to
be using Touch-Enabled One for
something like the tablet or
phone, or would Media
Query suffice?
BORIS SMUS: Right.
So the beauty of this approach
is it basically scales to any
sort of device or form factor
that you might have. So if you
imagine some sort of ocular
implant thing, like something
completely crazy, all you need
is you implement the media
query for it, and then you
add your Link Alternate.
PAUL IRISH: I wonder if Google
Glass will have a media query
that's appropriate for it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ERIC BIDELMAN: This
is cool, man.
PAUL IRISH: So right now, you've
created support for
Touch-Enabled.
I wonder if there's room for
more of that in the future.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, that's kind of
my hope here, that we don't
need to create these things
but they just exist.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Boris,
are you trying to
push the web forward?
BORIS SMUS: Actually
yes, Eric, I am.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
fantastic.
BORIS SMUS: It's what
we do here.
ERIC BIDELMAN: One library
at a time.
BORIS SMUS: So there's a CR bug
that's linked to from the
GetHub page.
You should probably go
to this and star it.
Only nine people have
starred it.
That's sad.
Can we have like 10 or 12 people
star it right now?
BORIS SMUS: Awesome.
Thanks, guys.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is
a great feature.
This should be enabled by
default in browsers for sure.
You said Firefox has this
if you enable it
on a flag or something?
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
So Firefox, I think it
should be in the
stable version, I believe.
I haven't tested.
So even in Firefox, I'm not
falling back to the Moz
[INAUDIBLE], I'm just using
modernizer, actually, to check
for touch support.
So that's basically
how it works.
I know there's some caveats,
some strange configurations
under which it won't.
ERIC BIDELMAN: By the
way, speaking of
Modernizer and touch.
I know I asked you this question
the other day, but
this will be valuable
for viewers.
Dev Tools has the ability
to simulate
touch events, correct?
BORIS SMUS: True.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Does Modernizer
detect those as well?
PAUL IRISH: Why you
gotta do that?
ERIC BIDELMAN: I was
pointing that out.
I ran into the issue, and maybe
somebody else is having
the same problem.
BORIS SMUS: Actually,
can we show that?
PAUL IRISH: This is really handy
if you're doing mobile
development.
BORIS SMUS: This isn't
on Canary, though.
PAUL IRISH: You mean
you don't have it?
BORIS SMUS: I have it, but
I'm not running it.
PAUL IRISH: Well.
One second.
We'll try--
BORIS SMUS: I don't think Touch
Simulation [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: That's possible.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Well, you could
show your laptop again.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
probably could.
BORIS SMUS: I could
just open Canary.
I mean, this happens
to be stable.
Yeah, let's do that.
So there's been a few things
landing inside Chrome Dev
Tools that makes it awesome for
mobile, and one of them is
you're now able to emulate
touch events.
Well, there's really been
no good way to do it.
There's been some JavaScript
libraries, which have tried to
map it over, but now we just
have first class support for
it in the browser, so it's
pretty powerful.
And so I'll show you now how
that works, and some of the
other mobile features that
we have available.
Could you dock that baby?
BORIS SMUS: Docked.
PAUL IRISH: Sweet.
BORIS SMUS: It's like some
features are already on.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, check
this out.
So we also have another
feature to show you.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh wow,
look at this.
So many features.
So you open up Settings, and
then now you have this.
You can override the user agent
and say that you want
the Network User Agent to be
sent out as IOS5, or any of
the other possibilities.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Wait, I know
the best feature.
Can't you Control Zoom in
on the Dev Tools now?
PAUL IRISH: It's true.
BORIS SMUS: Whoa,
look at that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is the best
feature, especially if
you're presenting
the Dev Tools.
PAUL IRISH: That's right.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And we can do
that because it's a web app,
it's a web app.
PAUL IRISH: So Chrome
Dev Tools is just
JavaScript and CSS.
So Control plus Nav zooms.
It's pretty newish.
BORIS SMUS: Did you know that
changing the User Agent also
sets the dimensions?
PAUL IRISH: What?
ERIC BIDELMAN: That actually
is really hot.
BORIS SMUS: Wow.
That's really nice.
I didn't know that.
PAUL IRISH: Wow.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So I know when
I've done mobile development,
I have a little JavaScript
[? bookmarklet ?]
that opens my screen to a
certain width and height and
everything, maybe I'm
doing some UA
detection on the server.
This kind of replaces that?
I mean, this is really nice.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So we have the device
metrics so you can
customize your own view.
If I turn it off, it kind of
just expands it back to the
full view, but I'm compressing
down the page to match my
device metrics which
I can customize.
Also, the Font Scale factor and
Fit Window, which I'm not
yet sure exactly what it does.
BORIS SMUS: Can you try it?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Try it.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
it does that.
So does that help, guys?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Actually,
we should bring up
a responsive page.
Is this a responsive page?
PAUL IRISH: This is not.
BORIS SMUS: Just pull
up mediaquery.es.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And just
show what happens?
That's another way to do
really quick responsive
testing is to now use
the Dev Tools to--
PAUL IRISH: Right.
So this is pretty cool.
Because in the Dev Tools I can
now set up, just change the--
let's try to go down to Five.
What's a [INAUDIBLE]?
BORIS SMUS: I guess you
can't [? zip the-- ?]
PAUL IRISH: Wow.
That works.
So we can do that.
And also another way to handle
your responsive design
development is I can just Dock
to Right this entire thing.
And if I Dock to Right my Dev
Tools, I can just bring this
over and squeeze down that
content as much as I want.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's cool.
BORIS SMUS: How did
it do that?
PAUL IRISH: Magic.
ERIC BIDELMAN: If you refresh
this page, right?
Does it refresh the
Dev Tools as well?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
It brings it all back.
So I think what we're trying
to show, before we got a
little sidetracked, guys--
ERIC BIDELMAN: There's just so
much really cool features.
PAUL IRISH: There's a
lot of good stuff.
Emulate touch events.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Emulate
touch events.
PAUL IRISH: So I'll turn it off,
because that's how it is
by default.
I have this little demo page.
It's a multi-touch demo, so you
can load it on Android or
IOS, and just use multi-touch.
It draws it on a canvas
element, and it works.
So the fact that you can do
multi-touch in JavaScript and
Canvas is kind of, not many
people know that.
But you can tell it
doesn't work.
I'm clicking on it
now and dragging,
and there's no touch.
But I turn this on, and it's
totally working, right, guys?
BORIS SMUS: That's
amazing, Paul.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's
because you're
painting in white, right?
You're painting white
lines instead of--
PAUL IRISH: Wow.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Demo fail.
BORIS SMUS: Hold on, maybe it's
some sort of-- maybe the
internet is down.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is a
feature, that Dev Tools is
killing the internet,
Brand new feature.
This is simulating offline,
which is a great segue.
PAUL IRISH: Perfect.
So I encourage you to check it
out, emulate such events.
It works, and it works well
when you're [INAUDIBLE].
BORIS SMUS: It's Canary
[INAUDIBLE].
It happens.
Maybe your site's down.
PAUL IRISH: My site
must be down.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Uh-oh.
PAUL IRISH: That's
embarrassing.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
really embarrassing.
PAUL IRISH: So speaking of
offline, one of the big tricks
dealing with offline
is that you need a
mechanism to store data.
And we started off with local
storage, session storage, and
then there's Web SQL database,
but now that's
[? deprecated, ?]
although there's varying
support.
IndexedDB is the new hotness,
and there's increasingly
better support, but
it is a mess.
But there's a new APIs--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Well, there's
one API that I'm
particularly fond of.
BORIS SMUS: Which one's
that, Eric?
ERIC BIDELMAN: So that's
the File System API.
So there's an API that's been
specced out in W3C,
[INAUDIBLE] in Chrome, been
available for a while now,
called the File System API.
It's my baby, I wrote
a book about it--
I'll push that--
and I wrote a library called
Filer JS to sort of wrap the
library, and you can pretty
much call Unix commands.
So there's a Copy function,
there's a Move function.
PAUL IRISH: So [INAUDIBLE]
API, just to be clear, is like
you can create files, you can
create folders, you
can move files.
Think about moving files
and folders on a
regular file system.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's exactly
what you'd expect in
JavaScript, yeah.
PAUL IRISH: It's the same
thing, except you have a
JavaScript API for it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is great.
BORIS SMUS: But you can't go
to your file system, right?
PAUL IRISH: It's sandboxed.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's an important
distinction, and
this is something that always
comes up, is you can't just
open a file system and read from
My Pictures folder, My
Music folder.
It's very much a sandbox view
of just your applications.
Your applications can read and
write folders and files to
this view, but another web app
can't access that because of
the origin policy, and you
can't break out of that.
So that's a great distinction
to make.
But it's exactly what
you'd expect, right?
In JavaScript, you can write
files and store them, you can
cache them.
PAUL IRISH: Big files too.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Big files.
So using the Quota API, you can
store whatever you want,
unlimited storage as far
as quota is concerned.
So this has a real advantage of
being able to cache things
offline as one big use case.
Say you have a music app and
you want to cache MP3s or
something, or files.
You can do that and make a
folder for all your rock, or
all your pop music or something,
and then delete
that at will.
So it has some advantages
over other offline APIs.
App Cache is a good example
people really hate.
It's hard to work with, it's not
very dynamic, you have to
[? create ?] manifests
and keep all those
assets up to date.
If one thing in the manifest
changes, everything's
downloaded, it's not great
for mobile, that's
not great in general.
BORIS SMUS: You can't
add anything to your
[INAUDIBLE], right?
ERIC BIDELMAN: You can, but
you have to change the
manifest, but then everything,
right?
If you're saving a--
BORIS SMUS: But for JavaScript,
you can't?
BORIS SMUS: You can't, right.
Programmatically you can sort
of say, I want to add this
file, I want to subtract this
file, you have to work with
the manifest. And in
my opinion, it's
a pain in the butt.
So my love for the API is
apparent maybe, but I want to
help bring this File System
API to more browsers.
So like we said, it's only
in Chrome right now.
But today actually,
I will be seeing--
I had a blog post
about it today,
hours before this hangout.
I'm releasing a library
[INAUDIBLE]
to blog post. It's called
IDB File System.js.
And essentially what it is, it's
a polyfill library for
the File System API.
So the way it works is
pretty interesting.
I had to wrestle with not only
the File System API, so I had
to implement that entire thing
in JavaScript, but the
underlying storage, the reason
this works in other browsers,
is that it can take advantage
of IndexedDB.
So IndexedDB is sort of
this up and comer.
Firefox has it, IE10 will have
it, Chrome certainly has it,
who knows if--
PAUL IRISH: It'll be coming
in [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC BIDELMAN: So everyone will
likely have the IndexedDB
API pretty soon.
This is sort of my attempt to
help that in the immediate
future, and File System.js
essentially a polyfill.
How would you explain
a polyfill, Paul?
Library.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, it has the
exact same APIs as the
standard implementation, just
delivered via JavaScript
instead of the browser
delivering it.
So it works the same way.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So I have a good
demo of this working, if
you can switch back to
the demo machine.
Do you have Firefox,
by the way?
BORIS SMUS: Probably
an old version.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So this is a demo
that I put together, and
this demo runs both in
Chrome and Firefox.
Unfortunately, I don't think
Boris has Firefox that we can
bring up right now, but this
demo would work perfectly in
that using IndexedDB
as a storage layer.
But this is great.
So I can write a web app now
that uses the File System API,
and it's going to work
cross-browser.
So what this is doing is
essentially I can just have my
root folder here, we open the
file system using our File
System API calls.
We'll create a couple,
folders test.
So this is just using the
methods that the File System
API implements.
So we can create a blank
folder, a blank file.
I can drill down into
these folders.
I can zoom.
Zooming's good.
So you can see, I created a
folder, Test, I'm in that
folder, Test, right now.
So I refresh, my data
is preserved.
So I still have my folder that
I created, my empty file.
Do you have any files we can
drag into this web app that
aren't risque?
PAUL IRISH: That
aren't risque.
Well.
BORIS SMUS: I don't usually
have such files.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Do you
have like a basic
text file or something?
An image would work great,
some kind of image.
BORIS SMUS: Let's do
a big spooky fire.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Big
spooky fire.
Fires are spooky.
BORIS SMUS: Big spooky fire.
My computer is busy upgrading
Firefox, I think.
ERIC BIDELMAN: No problem.
BORIS SMUS: Should we
just drag it in?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Drag it in.
PAUL IRISH: Whoa.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So using the
power of drag and drop, we can
add that file right to
the File System API.
Imagine this was in Firefox,
it would be
the exact same process.
Just to show you [INAUDIBLE]
that was added, we hopefully
clicked that, and displayed
big spooky fires.
We're just completely
crashing right now.
But this is cool.
So now, I can use File System
API and all of its benefits in
other browsers.
PAUL IRISH: So it's File System
API built on top of
IndexedDB, so that means we
now have the same API
available, first of all in
Chrome, but with the polyfill,
in Firefox and IE10, and any
future browser that supports
the IndexedDB, so mobile
browsers in particular.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Mobile browsers
in particular.
Caveat, I haven't tested
it in IE10.
PAUL IRISH: I took a look.
ERIC BIDELMAN: You
took a look.
What happened?
PAUL IRISH: I took a look, I
[INAUDIBLE] in Browser Stack,
and I think I saw
an exception.
Probably not your fault.
It's not your fault.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Don't
worry about it.
PAUL IRISH: It might
be your fault.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I
want to show--
so there's also another
demo that I wrote.
Oops.
So if you want to play around
with library, go ahead.
I'd love your feedback.
And absolutely, like if you
have Pull Requests or
something for IE10 bugs or
something, I just haven't had
the time to test. But Firefox
works flawlessly.
They have probably the
most up to date
implementation of IndexedDB.
So this is another demo I wrote
when I wrote Filer JS,
the wrapper library that
implements Unix commands.
And you could see, sorry for the
small screen, but it's the
same demo, and it's also now
working just out of the box
with this library dropped in.
It works out of the box with
Firefox, with other browsers
that implement IndexedDB.
So I can traverse in these
folders, as you'd expect, I
can add files, I can
import files, I can
preview those files.
So this is cool.
I'm really excited about this.
Obviously, my passion for the
API comes into play, and I
think it's got a lot of
advantages over some of the
other offline APIs.
PAUL IRISH: Did you say
that that demo is
using Filer JS as well?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So great point, Paul.
I Didn't say that.
Maybe I did, I don't know.
But this demo is using
the library that I
wrote, Filer JS.
PAUL IRISH: So this is like
a sweet sugar API.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's a Sugar API
on top of the [INAUDIBLE]
File System API.
PAUL IRISH: Because that
API [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's good,
it's powerful.
We all know it's powerful.
PAUL IRISH: But I would love
to just [INAUDIBLE] and
[INAUDIBLE] and all that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: [INAUDIBLE],
copy, LS, current working
directory, all this cool stuff
that you're familiar with.
Basically, this library now,
the IDB File System, is
sitting on top of Filer.
So they're working together, and
this demo just works out
of the box thanks to that.
BORIS SMUS: So I think Mozilla
had some sort of large file
supporting IndexedDB?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
BORIS SMUS: Do you know
anything about that?
ERIC BIDELMAN: I think you're
asking about supporting binary
data inside of--
BORIS SMUS: So they had some
specific extension for large--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Interesting.
BORIS SMUS: So Mozilla had an
extension for large file
support, I think in IndexedDB,
but I don't
really know the details.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So actually, this
project started off for
me as a sort of investigation
if you could store files--
it's been said before that you
can store files and really
replicate the File System
API inside of IndexedDB.
So I went down that path
expecting to fail, but it
actually turned out
to be possible.
Firefox's implementation, in
particular, has the ability to
store binary data
in IndexedDB.
So as soon as I saw that, my
eyes opened up and said, hey,
you can polyfill an entire API,
which it's not a small
API, if you look at
the code base.
We can pretty much polyfill the
entire API and replicate
it using IndexedDB as sort of
the underlying storage layer.
BORIS SMUS: Awesome.
Very cool stuff.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So great for
mobile, great for other
browsers, great for building
an app that works offline.
That's all I had for me.
Do we have time for questions?
PAUL IRISH: We have time
for one question.
ERIC BIDELMAN: One question?
PAUL IRISH: So this came in over
the moderator during our
conversation.
And the question is coming in
from Stephan in Berlin.
And he asks, I wanted to start
a Chrome app based on
Backbone, Underscore,
and Require.
However, the Chrome App Manifest
Version Two won't
allow CSP libraries using
a [? Val New, ?]
which excludes all known
JS type of frameworks.
Is there a solution for that?
This is an interesting question,
and I think we're
looking into it.
Basically, one of the things
that we're excited about is
getting better CSV
support inside
external JavaScript libraries.
So basically, if you rely on the
function [? constructor ?]
or eval, that means that that
JavaScript library won't work
in a CSP environment.
CSP is Content Security
Policy.
It's a new security model.
It's pretty exciting,
and it's coming.
There's good support for it in
Firefox and Chrome right now,
and Chrome apps will
be using it.
So basically I would ask, if
you have incompatibilities,
they have to be looked
at the library level.
So try and see if there's a
way to work around that.
One of the ways in particular,
with templating libraries, is
any precompiled templates
are not using eval.
So precompiled templates are
the way to get CSP support.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's generally
a good thing.
You should be compiling
your templates anyway.
PAUL IRISH: Way faster.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So it's
good for performance.
You should be doing
that already.
This is just nudging, hopefully,
developers in the
right direction.
PAUL IRISH: So that's
your solution there.
But is that it?
BORIS SMUS: I think basically
that's a good thing.
One thing is I think Mustache
doesn't precompile, but
Handlebars does, and probably
other templating
agents do as well.
PAUL IRISH: Precompile them.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Good thing.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
Well, I appreciate you
guys watching, and--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Thanks,
everybody.
PAUL IRISH: We'll be back
soon again [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC BIDELMAN: See you again.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.